hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today
is my friend tom scott tom
is returning for his second appearance
on the show he is the
founder of something called the
nantucket project which is
essentially an ideas festival along the
lines of ted
or the aspen ideas festival uh the
occasion for today's conversation
is a recent project that he's working on
called
american neighbor where he a few others
in a film crew
traveled along the mississippi river
from
minneapolis all the way down to the
delta
in new orleans to have conversations
with
everyday humans about race in america
about covid about the
common things that we're all currently
struggling with
this is a really profound and amazing
conversation with a truly extraordinary
individual
somebody again i'm proud to call my
friend so
without further ado please subscribe to
this channel if you enjoy the content
hit that notification
bell so you can be alerted when a new
video pops up
and with that i give you me and tom
scott
[Music]
good to see you good to see you it's
been a minute
yeah a lot has happened since the last
time i saw you
yes on the island of nantucket for the
nantucket project last year
and i'm anxious and interested in
hearing about what you've been up to
because it's
pretty fascinating yeah it's been a week
it's been i mean i know this is true for
just about everybody
like what a year what a year i don't we
won't make sense of this for a long time
you know
but uh i i think it's you know there's
good and bad in it
for sure i can i know that's true for me
and i want to say respectfully that
that's not true for everybody
it's been a dramatic right year
and in many ways i think um the most
unpredictable
of our lives i don't know how you
measure that but that's how it feels
just when you think we have a grip on it
another curveball gets thrown
yeah there's nothing that's out of
bounds this year
and you know i would say also i have a
lot to be grateful for i'm
extremely privileged i get to continue
to do what i do
to make a living my family is safe and
healthy
but it's been trying in its own way i
think the thing that i
struggle with at least with respect to
the pandemic aspect of this
is is grappling with
i hate the word new normal because it's
not a new normal but
but trying to get my hands around
this reality that we find ourselves in
where
it doesn't appear that we're gonna
resume
any sense of what it used to be like
like this is just how it is for
the foreseeable not just immediate
future but
as far as i can see and it's challenging
when you can't make plans
and you struggle with what to look
forward to
and how that plays out on all of our
psyches
individually and culturally yeah well
and i think it's also you know
we use the word wonder for learning in
our organization
and for us it's sort of derived from a
hope for
a humble approach to learning right to
have the humility to learn
um that sounds haughty but it's true
that's how we talk about it
i think it's hard not to feel humble in
this time
because of what you said because i don't
know i don't know what's coming who
knows what's coming you know
there's certain ways you can look at
that but
the truth is i don't know you know i
just think about my kids
my son's football season was just
canceled these these are these are
little problems generally speaking
generally speaking
my other son was just you know he was
going to go back to school and then
now he's not this all happened in the
last week you know and there's certain
things i
observe in them that are scary i guess
scary in the sense that
um they're certainly not having my
childhood
right they've got a whole different
childhood going on here completely yeah
and so that's just one example
of the unknowns i mean because i could
very easily build an argument that
suggests
this will make them stronger different
more humble and i can give you the other
one
right the other great resentful yeah the
sense they're being robbed oppressed
certainly depressed you know i've got a
16 year old daughter who is in
an art high school which she loves
the practical aspect of creating art
with other kids
and with mentors now she's on zoom from
eight to four for classes and then all
her academic
homework is done on the computer and
then she has to do her practical
artwork by herself and
she ain't happy you know this is this is
it just makes me think this is
this is horse [ __ ] man this is not what
being a kid is
yeah this is terrible and for all the
talk of how unhealthy it is
you know all this screen time to then
pivot to like well you got to be on
screens
all day long from the moment you wake up
in the morning until you you go to bed
at night
yeah yeah and only time will tell how
this
plays out ten years from now when this
generation of people
who have undergone this you know
extraordinarily trying
experience what what kind of people
they're going to be and what their world
world view is going to be yep you know
you know phil williams
phil williams is a guy that you and i
went to high school with um who now runs
a camp in vermont
the camp that my children go to uh he
opened this summer and they did four
weeks
at a sleepway camp amen
you know god bless him scary and i talk
i was in touch with him a lot and you
can imagine the risks he's afraid
there's
health risks there's reputational risks
there's financial risks
he pulled it off they all went they were
all there a month
they all came home nobody got sick
nobody got sick that's good
yeah so it can be done but you know he
was getting nasty letters from other
camp heads and
you know and to his credit he's like i'm
gonna do this and and it's funny because
he he will have a net negative
financially speaking he'd been better
off keeping the door shut
um but he said you know how often
parents tell me this is the most
important thing in my children's lives
and he's like so i'm opening this is
important
and he did it you know now that's not
easy i mean there's certain elements
that he has
isolation geographical isolation
um you know certain demographic
right so there's certain things he could
do as a camp head that would be harder
to do elsewhere
but these challenges to your point uh i
don't know
both that it's the definition of a
dilemma staying home isn't
a good idea necessarily either going has
its risk saying home has its risks
he took a calculated risk and did it and
it worked right
yeah it's difficult to grapple with the
nuance of it all
i think when we talk about the health
risks of of covid we have to also talk
about
the mental toll that's being placed on
young people to be
in this kind of isolation and what that
cost is that we're
incurring and look you know i wear a
mask
everywhere i go i'm basically at home
all the time
except for the occasional trip to the
grocery store and then when i come here
and we're as safe as we possibly can be
and you know half my conversations are
now on zoom which is
trying you know it's not my favorite
thing this show is about
being with people you know it's very
much in the ethos of what you try to
create with nantucket project it's about
having an experience with another human
being and i really struggle with doing
that
on zoom and again this is a small
problem in the grand scheme of
everything that we're grappling with
right now
and i just see so much confusion
and chaos and um discontent
and upheaval um a lot of the upheaval is
necessary
you know some of this chaos my hope is
it creates ultimately a stronger more
cohesive nation but we're going through
it right now as a country
and i can't help but wonder about what
the future is going to look like
for um you know not myself but
just just as a nation and what we stand
for
and what our values are and whether or
not we're going to
find our way back to a place of being
able to
communicate in an effective and healthy
way because that breakdown
that we're seeing is real you experience
this firsthand with this
um adventure that you just went on which
we're going to talk about
in a minute so what is your kind of
sense of
of where we're at right now yeah i mean
it's um
i can bounce back and forth on this
right i can i but i would say
what i would say is um i left my house
on may 5th
because i had to leave my house you know
i by the way i love my family and all
those things i'm sure
it's difficult for people in a whole
variety of ways to be in your house with
your family all the time
there's good in it but i move around
it's what i do
i interact like you i interact with
people
i go to meetings right i go to meetings
i did go to meetings
every day as part of my recovery and
it would be disingenuous to
not mention that because what i do every
morning is i wake up and i go
interact with people in a meeting pretty
much
at least six days a week it would be
seven if i had the schedule time
it's a critical part of who i am and
that went away
um i was doing zoom meetings and that's
okay
it's better than zero but so i left on
may 5th and i just wanted to go out and
see what was really happening in the
world because
i do not trust it here's i want to be
clear this isn't about
fake news this is about you cannot
perceive the world through your computer
and your tv it just doesn't work
it's part of the story and just to
contextualize that i mean you
you do this every year like you take a
train across america
right and part of the intentionality
behind that
is to connect with real people to get
behind kind of what we see in our
twitter feed
to experience where people are really at
when you interact with them in a
meaningful
tactile way yeah i mean i'm going to
jump to the conclusion which
i'm not giving away the secret here i do
not believe that there's any life
challenge
any important life challenge that can be
solved without conversation
i don't believe it i just think that's a
fundamental fact
and the more time i spend looking the
more i stand by that i think it's just
a fact it's always been it's always been
only recently do we have to lament its
departure
because we have found a
dopamine driven stand-in for
communication and it's not all evil
i'll get on my phone when i leave here
for sure like you know i'm no saint here
but it has really screwed us up
it's really screwed us up i would agree
with that 100 percent
and it's one of the reasons why i'm
doubling down
on what i do here because conversation
matters and the the more that i do this
and the more tumultuous
society feels the more i feel called
to have difficult conversations to
invest in nuance because of the
breakdown that we're seeing
and i think that the only way forward
is conversation conversation matters and
it matters now
more than ever set against the backdrop
in which
this thing that is so fundamental to
being human
has been fractured and
you see the trauma our inability to
listen to be present with another human
being and to seek to understand
rather than to convince that's it you
know here's the here's an
here's a thought and and um i know you
know this
one of the things that's developed in us
is our righteousness you know
to be right is such a big deal in our
culture
and to be right is largely measured
through your rightness
on your social in social media largely
or how that measures up
against the tribe to which you describe
that's right
now that's really different than what
we're talking about here and and
you know if you're someone who has had
the blessing of
in the in the sobriety world people will
say i'm a grateful recovering this or
that
alcoholic addict whatever right that's a
common phrase if you're in this world
you know this
and as time goes by for me and i know
it's true for many or most
you really believe that you really
believe that you had the gift of being
forced to be get intimate with other
people
because it changes your life in so many
profound ways well beyond
stopping using a substance in an
unhealthy way well beyond
like that's just the tiny cherry on top
um and i just you know for me i i will
stand by that forever
but the point i wanted to make is the
beautiful stuff
the life-changing stuff the stuff you
never forget
it comes from everyday people it doesn't
come from the smartypants it doesn't
come from the
really intelligent person at yale
nothing wrong with that there's nothing
wrong with that i'm not trying to be
cynical here
i will just tell you that the people who
have profoundly changed me
most are regular everyday people with
regular everyday problems
and often the way they express their
beliefs their their challenges their
fears
isn't in really lame language they
stumble on their words as they're saying
it
that's what conversation is it is way
more
than like smart theories it is
completely transformational to who you
are as a human and and
i think it is also a place for you to
understand yourself
is to just be with other people it's all
that is lost that is lost right now now
there are those who do
see this and understand this but even as
i was speaking i was picturing these
people's faces there was a woman named
gabby in memphis who
she said i hear you guys speak with
language i don't even know how to use
and and then she told her story and and
who gives a [ __ ] what her sophisticated
language is or the theories that she's
ascribes to that has
that's meaningless you know i mean we i
as you know
you get these like shares on high when
you're in a meeting
and then you hear someone tell the truth
yeah that person who tells the truth
changes
everything that person who speaks on
high if you've been around for a while
you roll your eyes you just wait until
that time passes i'm sounding cynical
here but i just experienced it too much
recently
and i feel so profoundly
moved by it and i just i want other
people to experience it i want other
people experience
i think because i have love in my heart
i also like i don't want to live in a
world that's so [ __ ] up like this
yeah let's make a better world well it's
not going to happen if you just like
the book isn't going to do it it's not
going to do it
it is this hidden gift of of sobriety
and spending a lot of time in the rooms
you know we all know the difference like
you said between
the circuit speaker person who will
deliver this incredibly tight
taught unbelievably inspirational
you know kind of monologue about their
story and i think that has its place
but the emotional connection comes when
you hear that person who's just
working through their fear to be as
vulnerable and as real
as they possibly can and the courage
that that requires
is something that you don't experience
that often
and that having you know being a part of
that community and participating in that
informs everything about what i do and
in so many ways like the show is an
effort for me to like share
some slice or sliver or aspect of what
that feels like
yeah the healing that that that that
um creates another human being totally
well and it it it unlocks your ability
to love
because you can spend a lot of your
energy hating yourself
elevating yourself damning yourself
misunderstanding yourself i mean i said
yourself a lot right like
just spending a lot of time thinking
about yourself is just such a waste of
your energy most often
to really interact with other people is
to unlock that part of yourself that's
useful to other people like that's how
it gets unlocked
is by being with those people and
understanding these things
you know you talk about service it
doesn't have to be a soup kitchen
you know it doesn't have to be a place
you check in and check out of
it can literally be a phone call it can
literally be
a moment with your ch with your son or
daughter right it can
it can have it it can find its way in so
many places
but if you want to know what it is you
have to give you got to be with other
people
it's just you know fundamental part of
it
i had this moment so this trip which was
called american neighbor ended in new
orleans and i did not speak the whole
time
i would i would sometimes just introduce
myself but i was just there to listen
well finally on the last day i did speak
i spoke on the very last day
right at the very end of the the
gathering we did that night
and there was a conversation going on
about like what was the agenda of one of
our films that we showed
which is so interesting because we made
the film two years ago you know the it
the agenda had nothing to do with what
people thought it
had to do with and i said i just want to
be clear because i think it'll be
helpful to
if you want to understand our motive and
where our motive comes from and it comes
from 13 years in a room
that i discovered as part of a way to
become a sober person
if that never happened we would not be
in new orleans right now
that's why that's how we got here
now there's a lot of other elements that
came to play race politics
lots of you know covid for sure but if i
hadn't had this experience
we wouldn't be here we wouldn't make
these films we wouldn't tell these
stories
and and and i would add i would add that
i think our world is really messy really
messy
and i think if we try to leave
conversation out of the solution
it's just going to continue to be messy
or get worse it will
so let's create a little context here 10
years ago
you created the nantucket project
it's sort of an ideas festival in the
vein of
ted yep where you invite any number of
extraordinary luminaries and also a
variety of
extraordinary human interest stories and
people to deliver that message
and you invite a community of people to
attend
a rather small community you do it in
the ground
the intentionality behind this is to
spark and provoke
conversation on a variety of matters
i've been privileged to
attend two of them and participate and
you know i do a lot of conferences
um what you do uh and i've told you this
before really stands shoulders above
any other similar type of event that
i've participated in there's just
something really
intentional about how you construct
not just the speaker lineup but the
environment
and everything that that kind of occurs
around the stage so maybe talk before we
get into
like the the thing that you just did
like talk a little bit about
nantucket project like how it came into
being and yeah and how that experience
has
affected your life yeah well you know i
i always say the worst thing that ever
happened to me is the best thing that
ever happened to me and
life is long i'll have others right but
the things that surrounded my moment of
it's time to get sober were dramatic and
painful and bad like they are for
most people who go through a situation
like that in some ways it was built
through
a excess of
self-focus what we might call
success gone wrong right and that is
true
but i would add that it also gave me an
interesting glimpse at
a young age of sort of the silliness of
the world right to be exalted
is sort of silly it's a exalted like
what does that even mean like to have
money
makes you better to to to have like uh
likes or friends or numbers or whatever
it might be
right our culture praises those people
and i was one of those people who got
praised and
in some ways it destroyed me and in some
ways it gave me an insight that wow our
values are kind of screwy we have screwy
values here
and that very often maybe most often
because i've had nice things written
about me and
bad things written about me neither one
of them are accurate
i'm not the first to say that you've
heard that before
well you know what is the story of our
culture and and we we
we you know we came along at a time
where
you know the three networks turned into
3000 networks and then the three
gazillion networks when the internet
came along
and to win means you got to do drama
like drama is how you get clicks get
some dopamine going you're in good shape
don't get dopamine going you're probably
headed out of business right that's the
general rule of what the 90s and the
early 2000s taught us about media
and what gets lost truth like real value
meaning
it gets destroyed and so when i went to
i went to the first aspen ideas festival
in o3 and i was blown away by what i saw
i was also
let down by a variety of things i don't
want to pick on a competitor but
you know some of the elitism and whatnot
is a little bit painful to experience
and some of the
mutual admiration society aspects of
what these things have we have it too
is disappointing to me and but i but i
really did believe like wow to be in
front of other people and to actually
like generously express ideas and then
consider them and do something with them
is cool it's really powerful
and i was completely turned on by what i
saw
but the idea of starting tnp was
can you talk about these super
meaningful things can you build story
in a way that's useful to people over
time and that's really what we started
with and
and you know i became sort of a joseph
campbell disciple
around the year 2000 and and the part of
joseph campbell that i'm most
attracted to is this idea of you know
the
multi-thousand-year story
that man tells man and how important it
is everything's a parable
you know you don't learn through
statistics you learn through stories and
and so stories are
a big deal a really big deal but to tell
a story
requires a lot of things if you're going
to do it with with a certain level of
respect and so that was really what
tnp was built upon now i got to say like
like anybody else
i got to pay my bills i got to sell my
tickets i got to stay alive
and you know i had started something
called plum tv after i did nantucket
nectar's and it really failed as a
business
and the most you know my idea was i'm
going to make a for-profit pbs
and when that failed like it broke my
heart like it really destroyed me
and you know i didn't do it right i
probably made some bad decisions along
the way i know i did
not probably and that's so when we
started this i said
i got to pay a bill i got to pay the
bills every year
and the question is can we both pay the
bills and pursue these stories
in a way that's meaningful and that's
really what it was built upon and that's
what we started with ten years ago and
i'll add one more fact which is
i knew from my experience with nantucket
nectar's and any other life experience
i've had sports for example
is that you pay a price you're going to
pay a price you're not going to be great
in the beginning doesn't happen
it's not how it goes i'm not mark
zuckerberg this isn't like the one in a
gazillion business that's going to go to
the moon quick it's just not
so do you have the patience to go
through that process and that
is hard as hell i know your story well
you know this
i'm gonna imagine like you go back to
the beginning and you think like wow
what was i doing well you were learning
you were of course on a path
and you're learning in a in a public way
yeah right where you're
you're you're open to that kind of
critique yeah but
on some level you have to have the
courage to to do that
in order to get good at what you're
doing i mean all i see
you know i went to the ninth and the
tenth one right or the eighth and the
ninth
eighth of the ninth so you know i wasn't
there for the early years i don't know
what
the hard lessons are that you had to
learn but i saw like an incredibly
high gloss polished version of what i'm
sure was not the case in
year one through three right right um
and and and one of the things that i
that i'm struck by
is you know in this
intent to tell stories that are
meaningful
there's a there's a courage to take
risks
like even in year nine like you're
you're experimenting and not
all of the things are gonna work right
but you're willing to walk that high
wire act i mean you've got
you know there's like president george w
bush is here
you've got you know candace owens but
then you also have
susan rice and brian stevenson like it's
this mix that crosses
the um you know the the political divide
and is creating these collisions of of
ideas that are
provocative and don't always land well
yes that is true
and and uh i will tell you a good covet
news for me as i don't have to get
that stressed this september
are you relieved yeah yeah i mean it is
um
i have a september mode that is
really intense like super intense
i mean i i can't compare it to you or
anybody else's business i just know
september imagine trying to pull that
thing off oh it's
just crazy intense and i care
probably too much you know just like man
man do we put a lot of effort into that
and so you know i always think i and my
team
any anyone on my team who might be
listening this is probably rolling their
eyes but i always think of
serena williams that look on her face
when she's
in it she's not all smiles this is not
like smiles times this is like
war like we are in war and and we are
going to
give everything that we have in that
time like we are just going to
lay everything out there and i got to
tell you that there's this um
i don't remember what word you use but
sheen or i don't remember what you said
but
something about this shininess of what
we're creating because
yeah i want some of that too man do i
not want that to come at the price of
a truth and provocative is a great word
i'm so scared of that word because i do
not want something to be provocative for
provocative sake and that doesn't mean i
don't want to be provocative because
that would be a misnomer
drama matters you know it matters it's
an interesting
but are you are you negatively pursuing
it or are you doing it in the pursuit
of something that takes you to a new
place and i want to believe we do that
you know i want to believe that we do
that every time you know the other part
that i'll add to that which i think is
so important
i mentioned the elites earlier
i mean you know i'm i am i have no doubt
that people have
mocked me for my what looks like
eliteness right
or probably is too right it bugs me big
time
it bugs me big time because i don't
think there's that much wisdom in it you
know
and and well you're an easy mark i mean
you're a wealthy white dude you live in
greenwich
and if you're gonna sit across from me
and we're gonna have a conversation
about race
it's pretty easy to for sure take shots
and dismiss yeah you and me
for that matter yeah and you know we
have to call that out a little bit
before we dive a little bit deeper into
that like i'm
not unaware of this no no i know i know
um and on some level in this moment
you're disqualified from having a valid
opinion
about anything relevant on that topic
i think that's true i i would say that
you know when you get into
i think any one of these conversations
and that's an annoying word by the way
like the national conversation like we
need to have a national conversation
like i don't think when people say that
they're talking about the same thing i
i'm talking about because when i talk
about conversation i'm talking about
what we're doing right now or doing it
in a small circle right
i think everyone needs to be in this
everyone everyone needs to be in this
now when you start talking about you
know i didn't go on the road just now
with tom's theories
i did go on the road just now with tom's
forum
i just want to set up a forum where
people who can deliver these things
are given an opportunity to do that and
in many or most cases those are regular
people
now in some cases there are experts for
sure i mean experts have a role i i
don't
of course and so i don't really
apologize for that
like that part of it
if people would prefer i sit home
probably not gonna happen
but critical in this equation are two
lynchmens neil phillips and simon greer
yeah like you don't
you don't go on this trip
and you don't host nantucket project
in the manner you know in which you do
without those two individuals
no those and many other people yeah many
others of course but i i
you know those two guys particularly in
this you know mississippi adventure that
you went on
are critical in helping to facilitate
the kind of conversations that you want
to have so maybe
you know talk a little bit about who
these two guys are who
both played you know a massive role in
in the nantucket project itself over the
years yeah
[Music]
i have a thesis that there is a
meaningful role for white people to play
in responding to racism in this moment
white people created a racist system why
people benefit from a racist system
black people didn't create that system
and so it would be isn't it like weird
to say that black people
alone are going to solve it the thing i
have discovered along this journey i
want more from white people
i have been too satisfied with
the try not to be bad position
we should all be saddened embarrassed
angered by how far we've missed and
continue to miss
what were stated as the ideals of this
country
and how accepting of that
miss we've been
[Music]
i actually wish both of them were here
today i know it would have been great
i know and you and i've known neil for a
long time yeah right and
neil he's your best friend i've known
him since i was 14 15 years old
yep yep and and neil i knew this before
but i really learned this this summer
he has an amazing heart like this guy's
got like a
crazy heart he cares so much and he puts
so much love into everything that he
does
so neil is you know he's a native of
jamaica and he moved to the united
states when he was three
his parents um came to united states to
their immigrants they came to united
states to live a better life and
you know neil was a great athlete
good student and uh
you know he's he he's a six foot four
attractive charming black man
who has seen a lot right he's seen a lot
in his life and
and when any you know he was captain of
his basketball team
went to harvard and uh was also all ivy
and football
like he's just a guy who's had a lot of
multi-sport
superstar yeah and incredibly
charismatic
charming gracious present smart like
all the good things all the good things
and and maybe most importantly to this
story
wakes up every morning at a charter
school that he founded
in bradenton florida it's a charter
school for boys primarily
black boys um who neil will say
he doesn't love it when somebody says
the phrase keeping kids off the street
because that is not how he looks at this
he looks at this as
letting the light of these boys shine
the way it does and he's been incredibly
successful at running this
school now for about a decade so he's
um he's in the middle of it every single
day
operating his school dealing with
cultural political financial
issues of many kinds every single day
um you know and if you're familiar with
these kinds of
stories survival is
a question all the time so you're trying
to build a school
in a difficult area in this case
bradenton florida in an area that
struggles
you're trying to do it and pay the bills
and build it
build a ethos and succeed
from an academic point of view and he
does all those things
and because he does all those things
he's deep in it
you know he's deep in it and neil's a
guy who
for whatever it's worth could have
chosen a different life yeah he could he
could
make some money and get a bet on at
goldman sachs right
right he's a 54 four-year-old guy who's
completely dedicated his life to this so
neil was one who came
um on the road and also before you move
on uh you know
uh uh an extraordinary civil rights
leader in his own right beyond the
school
yep for sure marched with john lewis yes
yeah i failed to mention that he runs
something called visible men it's called
the visible man academy and the visible
men movement is his strong belief is
that
the narrative on black men in america is
way out of whack that there are great
stories of black men in america
achieving in all kinds of places in all
kinds of ways and
he would say primarily in the way that
they share love with the people around
them
and that america has an obsession with a
different story
and that story is detrimental to the
society at large but
importantly to you know the the black
society that he lives in and he finds it
very frustrating so that's what his
movement is and he
so yeah he's marched a few times with
john lewis and
i just you know that whole community
from brian stevenson to cory booker and
others
who um who he's worked with and so this
is his life
you know this is his life and you know
when we invited neil on this trip
by the way it i would have done the trip
if neil wasn't going right
there's no trip without dealing right
it's a misnomer to say that but
he i want to add that when you run a
school during covid
you are busy like he's got a lot of [ __ ]
to do so
taking that time for neil was a big deal
and but you know but he's a believer
like he's a guy who's going to stick his
his nose into things he believes so so
neil was one and then simon is the other
and simon
um simon greer uh he ran
and i'm gonna blow the title but he was
the sort of the lead
community organizer in the obama
administration who over the years
has run what you know what are called
courageous conversations with a whole
variety of
people from you know he's done a lot of
work in
the jewish community many communities
where he basically brings
strange bedfellows together to have
productive conversations is really what
he does yeah his whole thing
is trying to bridge this divide by
sitting down and putting himself in the
middle
of you know an incredibly temptuous
issue to try to unite people around
some sense of shared values and he does
it
at again like great peril to himself and
it doesn't always work out like you've
made a couple
you know films about the work that he's
done
you know his personal story and the pain
that he endured and and himself putting
himself
you know in front of people that he
disagrees with profoundly to try to find
some commonality
and in that is this great hope and
aspiration
that this is the solution to what ails
us like he
he despite trying and trying and trying
again
he continues to show up for this very
difficult thing that most of us
shy away from or just think it's not
worth it man or
what's the point right that's right 100
true
and he's um you know
we started in minneapolis we started in
minneapolis so let's just say let's just
define it right so you go out you're
going to do this road trip
you you simon neal and a crew of people
are going to do this road trip you're
going to start in minneapolis and you're
going to work
your way down the mississippi river
and you're going to stop in towns cities
communities and create
gatherings at a safe distance in the age
of covid
to have difficult conversations about
what's happening in america
yep is that fair that's fair and i'll
just give quick way of background when i
was saying earlier
on may the 5th i finally said i got to
go see what this real coveted world is
so get out of the house i got to get out
of the house and me and another guy got
in a car
drove to the northern tip of the
mississippi river which is called lake
itasca way in northern minnesota
and we drove to new orleans and back
home through the mississippi delta and
we
stopped in muscle shoals alabama we were
in nashville we're in a lot of different
places
and it was profoundly affected me and it
you know and
i guess as just a way to think about it
i remember having a conversation with a
woman
a white woman trump supporter in dubuque
iowa in a convenience store
and i remember having a conversation
with a young black
guy in memphis
and um you know at that moment during
covid
they both were struggling in a big way
they both felt a sense of being left
behind
they had a strong sense of frustration
frustration on many levels among them
certainly money
you know because of the economic
challenges that came along with kovid
um you know on the conservative side
there's a lot of leftover anger from
being one of the basket of deplorable
types you know who
they feel like they've been forgotten
and insulted by the left
and then there's you know this one of
the things the kid in
um memphis said that will always stay
with me i asked him what was it like the
day after trump was elected when you
went to school the next day and he said
oh it's like any other day because we
expected it
you know meantime at brown university
they're protesting and going crazy
and in this case they're like he's like
we were used to this
we we know we're forgotten it was really
profound and so when i got home
um i don't know this is probably four
days before the george floyd thing
happened
um i was telling my friends and my team
i said the world out there is not the
world you think it is it is
we got to understand this like all this
stuff we're yelling at each other about
in social media on the news
is a myth it doesn't mean there's not
problems there are problems but they're
misunderstood
let's go back it's sort of that was my
feeling at the time
and then the george floyd thing happened
and
i don't know within nine days we were
ready to go back ready to go back and
and try to understand this and and so
and to document it
and to document and that that's critical
i mean i think the um
so so what we did was we um
did the exact same thing the the there's
one key difference and that is that
every you know
i drove out bunch of people drove out to
once again the northern tip
and then down we had our first event in
minneapolis and
basically over 13 days we did 11
planned events down the mississippi from
you know memphis dubuque st louis small
town called nava illinois
um we were in vicksburg mississippi we
were in
new orleans we were in outside of baton
rouge so we did them in
interesting and different places on the
way down that was
at night every night at eight o'clock
we'd started gathering they lasted two
hours
and then by day we'd follow up on people
so we
can we come see you tomorrow and we
interview we just did interviews the
whole
the whole time you know the thing i just
want to point out
i've made a lot of films over the years
and i've also been to a lot of meetings
over the years
the most profound things i've seen in my
life over the years has been in meetings
you don't bring cameras to meetings
right it's just not what you do
well in this case we from the very
beginning we said we're going to capture
this whole thing so we're going to
we're going to cover these we're gonna
have real crews
in these meetings the entire time and
was there a fear that by doing that you
would somehow
dampen people's uh you know
feeling of comfort to be honest and
vulnerable yes
for sure and we spent a lot of time
working on that
um including things like where are the
camera men and where do they sit
how do they sit back right all night all
that stuff
it turned out to be no problem i mean so
there's that and then the other side of
it is
neil and simon would run the show every
night like they would run the show
um and they are good at what they do
you know they're they're very honest in
what they do i think
really importantly they're ready to take
abuse because
you get abused right i think that's part
of it showed me like a
16 minute rough cut yeah some of the
footage
and you know simon really takes it on
the chin
a lot a couple times yeah yeah well i
mean you asked the question earlier on
which
is definitely the fair question like who
are you who's who's the mr elite guy
over here
you're gonna come down into middle
america and and root out the truth
right [ __ ] off exactly exactly
there's something that feels gross to me
about putting
vulnerable stories in front of white
people to get to them
and hopefully they'll care and hopefully
they'll change things at some point we
just need to [ __ ] move
and just let the movement move past us
if we cannot support it
it could be a convenient story that
we're going to just plow past
most of the white people in the country
the guy i met with yesterday
he told me about the hot civil war that
will come before 2024
and this is a fully armed part of our
country
and history doesn't teach me that we
plow over them
it's it's never been the story and so i
don't want a pie in the sky
uh anti-racist lecture what i want to
know is what is the
plan so that we can be the last
generation that lives this way
and if it's easy to target me i
i've been called a race traitor by white
people and are racist by black people
enough times
that i'm not pleased with it but i'm not
disappearing
so i think you're very smart but i also
don't like you the more i sit here like
it seems you have an agenda that was my
biggest fear coming here
i think you are part of the problem
because of the
rich liberal progressive agenda that you
seem to be pushing
so we're telling our truth here brother
you got to just listen i told you from
the junk
don't don't don't ask me to turn around
how i feel
you talk about the stones getting
unturned i i don't know that there's
any that got unturned like we heard it
all
we heard it all um and when it played
out
you know it really played out i mean i
could go down a long list of what those
things are but we all have these biases
of who's like that and you you're not
enough like this and you're not enough
like that and how would you know this
and how would you know that and all
those kinds of things
well okay i accept that and i think
there's some
truth to a lot of those feelings so now
let's talk about it
do we actually have the courage to talk
about those things
well those things got talked about a lot
um
so you show up in in minneapolis how
long after george floyd was uh
well it would have been um about six
weeks uh-huh
something like that um and it's intense
you know i remember when i went down i i
watched um
the second plane fly into the tower and
in on 9 11.
you know it was really dramatic and i
forget but like three or four days later
i
rode my bike down to ground zero oh you
were you
when you say wash it you were in
manhattan i was in manhattan yeah
and we talked about that before and long
story short
you know the minute i got up to like the
chain link
fence i was just crying like a baby
and it shocked me i'll never forget it
in the same way we you know with the day
we got there say let's go to the george
floyd memorial
which you know i put it into my google
maps and there it is
like it's already in there right there's
a pin there for
there same thing i got to a road closed
sign
and i got very emotional it was very
emotional
i didn't expect that i wasn't ready for
that but that's where it all started
you know that night we had our first
gathering
not not in that site there's something
kind of sacred or there seems to be
something sacred about that
site but nearby and it was
really intense like sad scary at moments
um hopeful too loving angry
like a lot it was a lot and we did it
two nights there so we were in
minneapolis for two nights
and simon right away was taken to task
right away
right away in what way like give me an
example
on the ways i think you said like who
are you what are you doing here the hell
do you know kind of thing
i think people made certain assumptions
about like what simon's role
was i mean to simon's credit and you've
seen him simon has his own political
beliefs but to say he has a political
agenda
i think is unfair his greatest gift is
in his ability to get people to
interact and when the [ __ ] gets heavy
to put it in a place where it can become
useful as opposed to just a big
big fight like that's really who simon
is i think if you think he's coming to
preach you
are you're biased like who is this guy
but it's not really what he does you
know but
it doesn't matter because in the end all
those feelings
are felt by people all over the place
right
the most powerful one and i don't know
what town this occurred at but it was in
your
in your edit was the conversation
around essentially reparations where
this individual was really pressing
simon and simon seemed to get a little
bit defensive
yep with this idea that that's you this
guy was basically like you need to give
up everything that you own
right and simon had a certain reaction
to that and then i thought neil
had like an extraordinary perspective
yeah to help kind of simon understand
where that person was coming from can
you walk me through that because that
was the most powerful
exchange yeah so you've looked at a
little bit of the footage i mean
i have we have so much footage
are you going to make like a
feature-length documentary out of this
or what's the intention
i'm it's one of the reasons i'm in town
i got to figure that out
i feel a very strong obligation to do
something with it that is most useful
i think it's actually best served as a
series
because a number of the people who we
met
have such powerful individual stories
and i think if you fill in those
blanks it becomes so much more useful
well it is episodic too you could do
like a
you know six eight hour
netflix series yep absolutely could and
and i think that
the stories of these individuals are so
powerful and that
and to understand sort of what they
bring to those moments
is also so powerful and i think putting
those two things together is really
vital
so i want to do that um the time that
you're describing
so that was st louis you know as you
might expect
first of all the questions that people
ask me at home in many ways demonstrate
the problem because a lot of the
questions people have are in many ways
unrelated to the reality of what you see
out there so just as an example
i had a couple people say asked me if i
saw antifa
out there not once you know that's not
what
it's not actually all over the place
it's not
that's just one example there's a whole
variety you weren't in portland though
exactly and
right but you know were people upset
about this that or the other things like
no this
is like a whole different level of life
you know
what about q and on never came up
no it never came up um but so what
happened was
i know why i was saying that i i said
that because a lot of people allude to
the south
i bet it was really bad when you got
down to mississippi
no and i think that these
these conversations the lack thereof and
then any degree of
them actually existing have been handled
differently geographically
in profound ways and if you live in the
state that is like the stand-in for
racism in america
which let's say that's mississippi well
they've been talking about it
like they know that they know the rest
of the country thinks that they're like
the worst
and on the other hand in illinois where
people think it's up north and it's more
liberal and more this or that
the worst of what i saw was in illinois
the worst
examples of racism i saw in illinois
i don't know how you measure that in
some ways you have to take my word for
it but um
and saint louis was like that you know
the the the anger in st
louis is really intense and the
well it's a it's a fair it's a fairly
segregated city
well exactly there you have it big time
like
it's not like manhattan yeah you know
it's not like new york city it's very
segregated
and so you know if you talk about things
like white fragility whiteness
white guilt white privilege okay you
those are important things and things
that we should all try to understand
and you know judge them for yourself
when you maybe understand it it's hard
to understand a lot of these things
but when you see it and you see the
reaction that it brings
it was really intense that guy's name
was hal
and hal basically does what a lot of
people in his position do which is like
i'm going to show you why i'm innocent
of all charges and
i'm with you kind of thing uh that guy
the other guy his name is tori he wasn't
having any of that
right so walk us through that so hal
basically talked about some of the
volunteer work he does in the black
community
um he said that there's a lot of good
people with good hearts in st louis
and then and i'm by the way i'm
paraphrasing and generalizing because
there's there's more to this but then
tori tori was the black guy who
talked to him about reparations and
talked to him like if you're
wife and child were murdered today would
you want to come here and have a
conversation about
who's racist and who's not tomorrow is
that what you is that what you believe
and he talked about you know well what
would you want me to do i'd want you to
give up everything you own
and he said is that a serious simon said
yeah are you being serious
right and being serious and he said 100
serious and that night was a
very emotional conversation around those
topics
welcome to racist st louis
i guess i feel a little resentment in
the blanket statement that
white people are all racist when i
happen to know a lot of really good
solid americans
here in st louis white americans
who are really trying to make a
difference in this city
and i hope that i could be counted among
them
i would assume that you would want some
brownie points
doing some charitable from some little
negro kids in north st louis
i don't do this for brownie points i
don't sit in a room with white folk
to be honest with you this is the
whitest i've been around
in probably about three or four years i
found another white person
who honestly believes
that what they're doing is what the
black people want
and that they're probably not racist i
found another
so-called ally why don't you tell me
what you think i should do
what i think you should honestly do yeah
i think you should
go get every white person and relinquish
all your things that's first
every single thing that you own every
possession relinquish
relinquish is that a serious proposal
that's 100 relinquished
how could it not be how would you feel
if i slaughtered your wife and kids
yesterday would you want to have another
conversation
would you want to talk about who's not
racist and who is
would you he eventually left that guy
left he got up and left you know and why
did he leave and should he have left and
who's right and who's wrong and all
those questions
you get to see it played out and and um
you know neil going back to neil
so there was 15 of us on our team so we
we
witnessed the whole story now i want to
qualify that we witnessed the whole
story from the point of view of the
events each night but during the day we
would divide up
and some of us would go visit different
people and interview different people so
the big story at night we all sort of
shared that together but we would all
come across these little stories
individually so we were all sort of
impacted in different ways and we're all
different people
but the point i'm trying to make here is
that the 15 of us would then meet each
morning and review what we heard and saw
and had and described how we were
feeling
you know we had 15 people all mixed race
all coming from different points of view
so you really got a
mix of opinions on things and um
and the thing i'll say that going back
in the very beginning i said
conversation is just so vital to all of
this
everyone evolved all 15 of us evolved
and all 15 of us at different times
found ourselves in different places
and what's interesting is that a day
later
two days later five days later we'd be
in a little bit of a different place
by the end i know i know because we all
said it we were all forever changed
i think we were all made more healthy by
it
and one of our mantras throughout was
don't let's not leave let's not leave it
in new orleans
i hope i hope and i don't know this but
i hope
that we're able to represent the things
we experience in such a way that other
people find it
as useful as we found it so that's the
hope
and that's why i'm saying that in in in
light of what we just described because
i want to respect those people i want to
respect tori
i want to respect how
you know they came and they were like
generous with their time and
generous with their honesty almost
entirely i mean we all are sort of
bullshitters and we're all a little bit
afraid and
certain people are probably more open
than others
but uh i don't want to in any way
disrespect what they gave us by
handling it the wrong way yeah i think
that their
my sense is that there's this impulse
on behalf of white america to just
figure out a way to heal and heal
quickly so we can move on yeah um
but in truth and what i think he did a
good job in portraying at least
in the clips that i saw is that you
can't have
healing without reconciliation
and a precedent to reconciliation
is understanding like these people need
to be heard like don't be so quick to
try to move to the healing part like
we're not there yet
yeah like there's a lot of work that has
to be done before we can even get to the
conversation around
healing and moving forward yeah you know
it's kind of like i mean what we were
talking about earlier
the the coveted confusion the where do
we go from here
feeling that we all have
and i think it's probably an instinct
amongst many people to
think by the way
it depends on who you are right it
certainly depends on who you are but um
let's get this problem solved so we can
get back to it
right well what is it what are we
talking about here we gotta get back to
our jobs we gotta
get back to letting the stock market
grow
like what what is it that we've got to
get back to well you could be you could
even take that a step
further i mean isn't that what make
america great again
is all about this idea of getting back
to some
idealized version of our past that's
rooted in fantasy and when you look at
covid just even in the shorter
term perspective of getting back to you
know the normal that we had a year ago
yeah what is that was that all that
functional now we have an opportunity to
deconstruct
all of this it's like we can look at it
like oh my god all this you know racial
uprising and then on top of that
a pandemic well perhaps the pandemic
is just god's way of saying all right
i'm really going to make you stop and
sit with this right now
and i'm not letting you out of the out
of the penalty box
until you [ __ ] figure this out yeah
there is no getting back to it
let's redefine what it is yeah yeah
that's right i don't have answers like i
really i again i
i'm sorry for being a broken record get
out there and start interacting with
people is the best i have i have my own
opinions on search but we're not allowed
to right now
i know i know well you know that's the
thing
i know but i do well let me say a couple
things about that one is i think
doing a version of a you know a virtual
conversation
which is what we've been doing is better
than nothing it actually i think is a
really useful
step towards something i mean here's the
thing i'll say i'm going to jump to the
last day and just
and there's going to be a corniness
factor to what i'm about to say i'm
giving you a pre-warning
but on the very last day which was in
new orleans
we the 15 of us gathered and you know it
was very nice of the people in new
orleans to let us stay in the space
because you know we're talking like it's
like 1am and they probably all want to
go and how are you
creating these gatherings you're just
putting the word out generally like how
are you figuring out who
who shows up at these things because
they weren't large gatherings
no they were like 18 a night right
covet you know we had coven challenges
and then also just a productive
conversation they were two hours long
and so if you think about two hours if
you get above 18 people you really can't
have a conversation
so uh but the answer is
there was three people on our team and
you know joe
you know joe yeah yeah yeah joe was just
an animal and and really went worked
so hard to find the right people to
gather each night
and we would show up in each town and i
don't want to diminish the work that a
couple of other other people booking it
did so
those guys were good too but joe is just
the most passionate person
you've ever come up with very
enthusiastic very enthusiastic
and so we'd show up in each place and
people say where's joe where's joe and
joe had these incredible relationships
by the way still does like we're still
interviewing those people you saw in the
film we're still interviewing those
people
because joe gets on and they talk about
it and this conversation is continuing
on
and this conversation is continuing on
on our platform in great ways
it's great i'm very proud of that i'm
very happy for that virtually
think of it as a version of zoom is how
we're doing those things
um but in these cases you know joe would
just
work it work it hard there's a woman
named jessica
who lives in anna illinois okay anna
illinois
the name anna illinois come it's what's
called a sun downtown
i didn't know what a sun downtown a sun
downtown means black people aren't
allowed after sundown
and anna the name anna comes from
ain't no n words allowed okay so
jessica runs black lives matter in
hannah illinois
jessica's a young woman she's probably
yeah maybe 30. and joe found her and it
was not on the route
so joe and i had to so drive off course
to go find her and speak to her
and she was beautiful
she was amazing this woman you know
she she describes her life like she'll
be walking down the street
every day and someone's going to call
her the n word out the window this isn't
illinois now
okay man was she just something else i
mean she she's
obviously hurt by a lot of this but
she's also just brave
and hopeful i'll never forget her i mean
you haven't seen any of that yet because
we haven't even gathered it all yet but
um
i bring her up because joe is so
passionate about making these
connections and meeting these people and
the places that it brings you is just
magical and there's only one answer to
that
and the answer is joe's passion joe's
belief
you know he's the erin brockovich yeah
exactly
yeah and then you know the generosity of
somebody like her to sort of bring it
out but um
man i was scared you know there's a
there's
this woman named tina on our team she's
a young black woman and
i don't know like the third day there
was a
loud pickup truck that drove by and i
got she could tell i got scared when the
person drove by and she's like are you
afraid and i said yeah
and she said are you afraid of the white
people i said
yeah and she's like why and i said
i don't know like i don't think people
like that like people like me
and that i don't i don't know like when
i see a rebel imagine being her
well exactly and she was like i had no
idea that
you know i thought all white people
didn't fear other white people and i was
like no i definitely fear that person
i bring it up in this context though
because while i was with jessica and
anna we saw it and i thought if i'm
if i'm jessica i'm definitely afraid
i would absolutely i would be afraid and
she
i think she is but she's also just has a
crazy courage um anyway
the answer to the question though is
conversation like that's how we met all
these people is you pick up the phone
and you talk to them and then you
connect with them and then you sort of
grow a relationship and that's really
what it was a lot of hard work
so what was the corny thing about new
orleans
yeah so um and i actually think it's
it's uh it explains well the philosophy
and that is we got to new orleans we're
here at the last
night and simon says okay
and you can roll your eyes at what he
said we are all going to
silently look each other in the eye
one by one as a way to
share how we feel about the trip so you
know there's 15 of us so i'm gonna look
at
14 in 14 people's eyes
and i was like uh you know this is
stupid um
but by the third one i realized
it was unbelievable and i'm bringing it
up because
one it's very difficult to describe in
many ways you'll have to take my word
for it
but but two that's what conversation is
that's what it is i mean literally
that's what it is
and that you know when we think of
conversation we think of it as
the words we share with each other and
that is such a small part of the
equation
it's being with each other it's the
emotions that we share it's the feelings
that and and the role that our eyes play
and the way we feel and the things that
we say
and so and and the sense that you're
being seen
yeah you know i've done i've done that
practice
it's sort of a yogic practice where you
sit across from somebody and stare into
their eyes for just a painfully long
period of time
yep and it does seem hokey but it is
you realize how little of communication
is actually verbal and if you sit
long enough across from another human
being and stare into their eyes
there is some deep profound sense of
understanding that you
ultimately arrive at where you're like i
i know this person
yeah it's it's crazy it really i don't
think it's
hokey or corny at all i when i
appreciate that in many ways i wouldn't
expect you to but i'm like a crazy
hippie
right well that's yeah and and i think
it is at the root of
what we're talking about here which is
you know the the what you saw on on film
there
that's not tom's theory of anything that
if i have a theory it's just if you get
people together and you do this
the greatest story the greatest theory
of the greatest
feeling will come out and so
you talked about neil and simon as being
critical definitely critical
those people you see there they are
the most giving useful brilliant
of all by far right you say that you go
into an adventure like that though
with as as a blank slate like i'm not
going here to
inject my perspective but we all have
our cognitive
biases so i would imagine that you had
some idea of how this was going to go
how it was going to play out and some
aspiration of
you know where you would arrive when you
got to new orleans
so how did this meet that or defy
that expectation like what what was
different
you know where did it go completely i
mean i can't imagine you thought
this is going to be kumbaya no no
you know but i would also suspect you're
an optimistic person that you would
think like if
and and with your conviction your belief
in the power of conversation that there
will be some
healing right and and and that was kind
of thrown back in your face a couple
times
for sure i mean i wouldn't say that
those moments surprised me i think what
did surprise me
was the way i and others evolved by what
they witnessed
um and the disagreements that we had
amongst our team
were really strong and very
unpredictable you know i wouldn't have
predicted the way that different people
would react to different things
that's got to be as much of the
narrative as
the conversations with the people who
live in the towns
for sure yeah yeah well and i think that
those
you know there's something about young
people
um now to be clear i think us old people
need it
we we need it badly but there's a
brilliance amongst people in their 20s
and we had a few of those
in part because they were raised
differently than we were
like their perspectives are just so
different
and some of the things that they said
and some of the ways that they reacted
i don't know i i you know you remember
the woman who said she was inadequate
from that film
she's amazing that woman is there's
something incredibly special about her
and so i sort of had the the gift of
watching
her evolution throughout this trip and
the things that she
learned you know because i think on a
certain level we're all pretty naive and
if you go through an experience like not
many people do this like who
who takes you know in my case three
weeks because there were there were
other weeks that we tacked on
or at least a week that we tacked on
there's more to this trip
which we don't really need to go into
but the point is
you're talking about you know in our
case a lot of 50-something-year-olds
and in their case 20-something-year-olds
and we didn't have time
there was a hurricane during it all we
missed that like there were so many
parts of regular life that we were
completely disconnected
from we were all in on this thing and we
were paying
attention like we were really paying
attention to what was going on on the
ground
well if you're doing that and you're not
living in your social media or in
whatever your regional bias might be
you're going to experience things that
you just have never experienced and
that's true across the board
so when you would see that with with
somebody like this woman liz who i'm
describing who calls herself inadequate
she's brilliant like the idea that she
would be
inadequate in any way which by the way
we all have that i don't fault her for
that
um and then to see her rise and fall
because there were moments where i saw
like hope and happiness in her and there
was moments that i saw despair and
anger in her um
that's an experience that's just
irreplaceable
so in light of that you know having
indulged in that experience
when you open up your news feed now and
you
see what's going on in kenosha how does
that
color or change how you process
what's happening yeah like
here we are again yeah it saddens me for
sure
um i guess
and it will take me time to sort of
understand how i feel about it
but the way i feel right now
[Music]
is very much
in line with what we said before which
is that there's something at play
here that is so much bigger than me
and that
the work is so vast
and it will
write its own path you know i i feel
like the very best we can do is
be at our best as we sort of roll
through the things that we're going to
continue to roll through next
it doesn't change the way i feel about
the power of conversation
and it doesn't change the way i feel
about the work
that we were able to witness on the trip
but it does certainly
elevate my own belief that this it
that we were going to go back to
is silly and that it
maybe kenosha is the it like that's the
thing we've got to go to like we've got
to go
to these places and deal with these
things
on a more important level i mean i think
in the end because you know you heard a
lot about
capitalism and other sort of structures
that exist in our country as the causes
of
the the challenges we have and without
taking a position on how i feel about
this that or the other of those things i
think one of our greatest
problems and challenges is that when you
think about prioritization
you know we live in a country that
consumerism and capitalism is
way at the top if not the top right
well what if they what if that was in
like the fifth spot
what if love was a number one and we
actually talked about it
and i'm in cornyville right now and i
know i'm in like utopiaville right now
but people in history have lived this
way i mean cultures in history have
lived in a way where the primary role of
the culture and the community
is to help the community in acts of love
and then beneath that is like they got
to feed we got to feed each other and
put the shelter in
but you know if you're living a culture
where consumerism is right at the top
well that's the
it that many people are talking about if
the it is
to care for each other well that's a
completely different question
like totally different and and when you
if let's pretend
capitalism and consumerism is at four
and five or three and four
well you're gonna have a very different
view on what capitalism and cult
and consumerism is if it's three and
four as opposed to it being one and two
and to me kenosha is a reminder of
we gotta be thinking about love is one
or two or one
i want to add that one of the big
debates throughout this whole process
was systems versus humans
love versus uh structure
like that was a big debate that kind of
went back and forth
throughout the whole thing and you know
i think what you see in kenosha
certainly has elements of both of those
things best as i understand it
yeah you know i'm thinking about
where anger sits and all of that like
i'm i'm thinking about
the the little clip in the video of
the hardcore trump supporter slash white
supremacists
that you come across and when you speak
of love and you speak of understanding
and conversation like
it's a sticky wicket right like how do
you approach somebody like that
who's entrenched in a very antiquated
way of thinking who
who uh you know is never going to be
able to see the world the way that you
see it
or come to some place of understanding
around
yeah uh you know race in society
yeah i know i know that's a real hard
one you know i'm going to add a little
bit
layer to that story which isn't the
answer but it certainly is
you know illuminating to a certain
extent
that guy um
about eight or nine years ago he became
a youtube
addict of a kind i know that in part
from him
and i know that from his neighbors
and he'll sell you too he's like he
watches youtube all day
and that algorithm knows that guy and
that guy gets the story he wants right
so he's been wherever he fell on the
radical spectrum youtube served to
further radicalize him
serves him all day have you have you
listened to the um
rabbit hole podcast series by kevin roos
no it's all about that it's all about
fascinating yeah
you should check that out yeah so i i
just want to say
that i don't know the answer to your
question but i do
know that the fundamentals that i just
outlined are part of the problem
and it's and you think about it like
who's running that algorithm you know
is it larry and sergey i'm not trying to
point a finger but
you know jesus that that's a bummer
isn't that supposed to be this
enlightened company that that
it's an ai that just is designed to
deliver you
more of what you've shown interest in
yeah if all you do is watch cat videos
then that's what your feed is gonna look
like
but you start going down the
quote-unquote rabbit hole
of a particular political perspective
then you're gonna get
served up more of the same yeah and
that's
problematic regardless of where the
where you fall on the political spectrum
because it will further entrench you in
your
perspective without providing you with
counterpoints
yeah get you to think more broadly yeah
oh yeah
i know and it's uh it's just a real
bummer
you know i find it very depressing and i
feel like you know one of the problems
and so every night when you
when you come to the conversation
we all come packaged in
[Music]
um nice little boxes that the internet
defines for us all day long
you hear it all day long you're one of
these and you're one of those and
i don't know like who who who who makes
these packages what are we talking about
here yeah
and and the antidote of course is to
contravene that
by having difficult conversations
between two people that share a
different set of beliefs
and like we said at the outset it
doesn't always go well like a perfect
example to me
and i don't know how you feel about this
but at the last nantucket project when
simon
had the conversation with candace owens
like i don't think that that went that
great no i don't think that we arrived
at
some greater sense of understanding for
different perspectives i feel like it
was
it quickly landed in a strange
uncomfortable impasse
yeah i think that's true and i applaud
you for
programming that like i think it was
compelling to
you know to see that and to wonder how
is this going to go
yeah yeah and i guess you know
to me it it's part of a path
to a better place you know i guess i'm
old school in the in the in the sense
that i believe
we should play these things out we
should have these conversations we
should learn these things and you know
it's who i am i read
i'll read right-wing books and left-wing
books and i'll listen to right-wing
things and left-wing things
i have my own strong opinions you know
some of the stuff i do online
i i i have a very strong feeling
and strong negative feeling towards
donald trump
i just i imagine i know a lot of people
do but a lot of people don't
right
and i mention that because
my strong negative feeling towards
donald trump includes
a willingness to hear what others have
to say about
his philosophies and his practices and
whatnot and ultimately for me
as a human i judge him as a human who is
unhealthy and destructive and divisive
and
detrimental to our world
and part of the way i get there is by
listening and observing and judging
and and i i'm just a regular guy i think
i think we're all capable of that
and i think part of what you've you know
the path towards discovering these
things is listening
you know and look in the end you know
some of the philosophies of
you know the ancients and learning and
considering and trying on and shedding
off
it's a big deal i think it's a huge i
think it's everything
i think it's everything i mean that's
you think about the meetings right
think about our our life in there you
hear a lot of [ __ ]
you hear a lot of bad [ __ ]
well if that were you know if it didn't
if it wasn't for the love of the people
who were willing to ride through that
and be understanding for people who are
on a bad path
can you like what's the alternative
there well it's an important distinction
i mean the difference being that that's
a safe place to do that
it's a judgment-free zone and people are
encouraged
to engage in their vulnerability in that
way right and the promise or the
the implicit agreement is that it will
be
received with love and compassion that
is
very much at odds with our current
cultural moment where
we're not allowed to make any mistakes
and we're not allowed to
evolve and a misstep can result in you
being
canceled forever and there's a fear you
know there's a lot of talk about like
first amendment rights like it's not
necessarily
a first amendment right but there is
something to the idea
that if you say the wrong thing in a in
a public forum
that the consequences are going to be
dire
and there is a chilling effect like is
it really worth
sharing my thought on this important
issue when the consequences are so high
like if i do it wrong
and so there's a withdrawal from that
conversation which i think is degrading
the productivity of our ability to reach
some level of understanding and to
grapple with these
difficult issues yeah it's much safer to
resort to the talking points of our
respective tribe to signal to those
and you know step back
from anything that is that even has a
hint of being
controversial or um you know is sort of
uh at odds with
party lines yeah yeah
yeah absolutely true and that's and that
lack of nuance
you know like this is like
this is part of why i like to do this
you know over two hours people are gonna
understand who you are
for better or worse right and without
that nuance i think
we're we're we're handicapping our
ability
to reach this level of understanding
that can
foment the compassion and the
understanding that we need to
to productively move forward yeah yeah
well i mean one of the things that i
have
learned the hard way more than once is
that
my own stupid theories
my own erroneous beliefs
are exposed to me when i say them
you know so it's in a conversation
that i discover things about where i'm
wrong
man what if i never got to say them
like would i ever evolve but there's an
impulse to be
teachable that's built into that right
and i think a
a lot of people aren't quite there yet
yeah they don't want to they don't they
they're not interested in
evolving in that way they're interested
in being affirmed for their perspective
right
right well i'm going to be the broken
record again and say that that's why i
so much believe in conversation if
there's one thing i want to get out of
bed and do and promote it's that because
i think that people can go on those
journeys and discover those things that
you know there was this woman uh well do
you remember the woman in
that where when the film opened that
older woman older woman yeah
she was the sage like that woman was
incredible
i grew up in a neighborhood of
storytellers
and you would fall asleep to the sound
of people talking we'll see you next
month
if nothing happens in the creek don't
rise
there was much more the culture of
talk on the front porch and in the
evening time
and i think um even today i think that
we
have lost a lot of that she reminded me
of uh of um what do they call her
in the matrix where they go to the um
the oracle
yeah yeah exactly i called her the sage
you know yeah
and and every word of her out of her
mouth was just such beautiful wisdom
and uh i feel like hers was the voice of
god
you know hers was somebody who's been
through it
and who ultimately i'm judging to a
certain extent although she did say some
of these
some things that were exactly in line
with what i'm about to say
you know she loves people through their
pain she loves people through
their struggle of understanding
i mean i feel like with um
so much of what you know as a white
person there's so much to be learned
so much to be learned
and some of it's going to come at a
great deal of pain
some of it's going to come at sat
through sadness right all of it's going
to come through some kind of an
experience
and i find for me if i just understand
the theory
it's not going to work for me it's not
it's not going to give me the thing that
that i need and i feel like what that
woman
said was you know love yourself and love
the others or
others around you as you go through this
experience and that experience is like
the dance of life i know that sounds
corny
we're having a dance of life on the on
the phone all the time
it's very unsatisfying and it's very
shallow in what it ultimately gives us
so you know going through those moments
in those times is like
is so valuable to me and i want to add
to um you know neil
is is neil phillips he took a lot of
abuse too
he took a lot of abuse from the black
community from the white community
and and there were moments where i saw a
neil that i'd never seen before
but i bring it up because
because i had the gift of watching it
over a number of weeks and
seeing the journey that neil went on you
know he's forever changed
and he didn't in what way well first of
all he didn't run from anything he
didn't have
to because this isn't the first time
he's experienced these kinds of things
but the idea that that that neil
in in sort of collaborating with you on
this
is is complicit more in the problem than
in the solution potentially yes
yes and and and by the and he gets that
in his in his work
like he's in i mean at a time he was an
outsider coming into bradenton florida
right well now he's been around for a
while and he's like of the community
but neil his energy and love
bends and and grows through that abuse
in a way that's just so useful and i was
really proud of him and
as i watched it you know there were
moments where
you saw it in the film there where he
you know was defending a kind of uh
like abusive interplay and in the in the
moment you feel like there's an
injustice
i felt like there was an injustice
you're talking about the reparations
exchange that exchange yeah and it
wasn't it the debate wasn't around the
right or wrong of reparations the debate
was around style
was around treating the way we're
treating each other in those moments
my take was that neil was pointing out
to simon
a blind spot when it comes to
his own white white fragility or
um the extent to which we process events
through the perspective
of of the the kind of dominant white
point of view watching the that
conversation continue over the next
couple days for those two
between those two with the backdrop of
those other
comments that neil gets it's you know
it's a really profound example of
the power of the love of an individual
that being in this i'm talking about
neil in this case
because the bottom line is neil is neil
just like we all are we all
you know it's like we we're not a kind
but we have so many layers to every
single one of us
and all the different inputs that come
into sort of defining who we are and
what we are
that notion that we're in like two or
three boxes and the internet knows what
those two or three boxes are
is completely destructive and and it you
know
i would argue that that is the
obstruction
towards some kind of a healing what did
you learn about
from neil and also just going down the
mississippi and
having these encounters about
the role of the white individual like
how can this
how can somebody who's white in america
be part of the change we want to see
like i think there's a lot of confusion
among white people about
you know not wanting to do the wrong
thing or say the wrong thing but also
you know be an active participant in
creating the world we'd like to see um
and not being sure
about how exactly to do that yeah
well i'm going to use very basic
arguments you know one is when brian st
stevenson says
be proximate you know the idea being
you've got to spend time around people
who aren't like you
there's a whole variety of ways of doing
that but i think if you sort of walk
around with that mantra
you know that's the reason i had to get
out of the house during kovid
because i'm not being very proximate
there's certain things i can do through
zoom or in our case our new platform
which i think is very real by the way
and then i think the other part is to be
really active in conversation with
each other and when i say each other
yeah if you can go have conversations
you know between different kinds of
people i'm talking race
largely when i say that but also with
people just like you
you know i think we got to talk to each
other about these things and really come
to understand what we actually think and
be willing to you know it's funny like
if you look in the this world
uncomfortable as mentioned
courageous as mentioned like you hear it
all the time
well if you're in a conversation and
everything's feeling great you're
probably not in a good conversation
right you know yeah and so that's what
we're talking about and it's like are
you willing to do that do you want to do
that
here's the thing i actually really
believe this that
almost everybody likes it likes it in
the sense knowing that there's pain in
it
you know it's like working out or any
other thing pain is part of the deal but
i don't think we'd work out and go
through these challenges unless we
didn't actually really like it and i
think that's
well there's an unmet hunger for
something that's real and authentic
yeah so that's my strongest
recommendation i mean
i'm gonna i'm gonna say that one of the
reasons i believe very much in film
deeper faster is the short answer you're
like why film
um you know one of the things that film
does
is it if done right it can model
people being courageous and people being
authentic
and like a good share in a room the
modeling is so powerful
and like the shares that follow tend to
be these really powerful moments and
these powerful opportunities
but i want to add a layer to that and
that is that
you know i was i was at a friend's house
this morning and i was watching her son
on
his ipad and he was he was on heroin and
he was like
fully locked a hundred percent locked
like you know hey
say hi to mr scott and and the kid was
just
completely we've seen it before i've
felt it before
uh because i do it too a good film it
can be a powerful antidote to that
can you know it's a bit like doing a
drug i always you know as an example if
you passed around a joint at a party
the conversation you were having before
the joint and after the joint are going
to be two different conversations
i think film can really serve to bring
us to a place where you're in a position
to have something that's really fruitful
and that's part of what i believe like i
really believe like share a story like
i don't know if you i'm sure you have
seen our acceptance film which is
one that is just powerful you could
watch that film and then talk about race
not that race and acceptance have
anything to do with each other other
than modeling like courageous
sharing uh i think that's a
really powerful tool really powerful
tool as an antidote to the phone
as an antidote to distraction as an
antidote to the fact that i mean before
we started today we meditated it brought
us to a place that was more useful
i think it serves that way at the same
time
it's a very binary thing there's the
there's the film
and there's the audience there's an
interplay between those two things but
in certain respects
it's static without you know
comprehending like including
you know a capsule to contain
the conversations that are incident as a
result of whatever that provokes in
people and one of the things that i
think is really cool about
what you've done with nantucket project
is capture that aspect of it rather than
just
here's the content you know it's just
here and available like
no the content is only as valuable as
the exchanges that take place as a
result of it
so you've created these neighborhood
projects where there's these they're
like tupperware parties for conversation
where
people get together they watch these
movies they have these conversations and
now you're really scaling it with this
new
digital platform where you're taking 10
years
of content that you've accumulated not
just
from the nantucket project event itself
but all the documentaries that you've
made over the years which
really have never seen a public audience
before and then
not just making them available but
really mindfully
curating a presentation of that content
that is
driving people to collide with each
other so talk a little bit about
like what's behind that and how you've
kind of arrived at this
yeah so um gather wonder practice like
those are our three
those are the tenets of everything i've
learned over these years you know and
and gather i think is obvious but get
with other people and have a
conversation like a huge part of sort of
i've said it too many times today in
this talk and i apologize
but um this notion of wondering
and i i mentioned it before this is just
a way we have a lot of stories now
most of our stories most of my work i
mean there are times when i take on an
editorial role
for sure right but by and large i just
gather people who
have editorial voices who tell stories
and you know when people ask like what
do you look for in a spirit
i'm always looking for spirit and the
right spirit it's it's so powerful on
what it what it does to people
and if people can wonder at a minimum
you know
often we think of that as learning it is
learning
it is also the greatest path into
humility there ever was
you know the more you know you don't
know the more useful it is
and the more you know you don't know
well now when you gather now when you
actually interact with other people now
you're getting somewhere
like that's what a good meeting is
that's what a good conversation is right
those two things together so
this notion of gather and wonder and
it's all manifest in this platform i
mean you can go and you can join groups
you can
you know have one group you always talk
to or you can go participate in others
but then the last piece being practice
you know i woke up this morning i
journaled i worked out
i you know i did i do a gratitude list
like these are the things we do and so
within that is this place which we call
kaleida
and kaleida is the place where you can
just keep track of
what we have nine of them like you know
reflection
um service community
just a place to keep track of those
things because i think those are the
things that
like what do i do now what do i do i've
i've taken this in
i've had this conversation how do i
incorporate this into my life or how do
i create a daily habit around
an idea or some aspect of
of self-care and community sensibility
that
will actually have impact on my life and
the life of other people right
right right and and you know i think
those are the things on a day-to-day
basis which
only only after time right can i reflect
and say man on a day-to-day basis do i
feel healthier clear
more able to help other people and
therefore more joyful there's a selfish
aspect to it for sure
only when i do those practices do i feel
those ways period
like that's just an absolute truism in
my life
so that's what this platform is meant to
do it's like a place to
to live that life i mean technically
speaking
a lot of the people you people you met
in that documentary and
we're you know we do conversations with
with those people right
you want to talk to those people you
want to interact with those people you
can do it through this platform
you want to talk about the things you
see you can do it through these this
platform and i think that part of it
i just think it's like a whole brave new
world um
i mean i have the gift of having been on
the ground and meeting all of these
people
and now i have some kind of a community
with them stronger or weaker depending
on each individual
well anyone can have that you know and i
think that part of it is
really cool i think it'll be really
interesting to see what happens with
that so when is it it's in beta right
now like this
platform hasn't launched yet what's the
idea yeah so we're gonna roll out on the
24th
of september we're going to do a
gathering that will be
about this so you know you come anyone
who wants to come can come it's on the
24th of september
um and it's at tnp.us which is
our home and uh
that's the day we'll open the doors and
anyone who wants to can come in and it
will all be built
around a conversation like you and i
just had on this trip so you'll get to
meet neil and meet simon
meet the characters who are on the road
uh we'll we'll look at film and we'll
have conversations that day
right so this is this this is this is
the stand-in for tnp10 exactly
basically exactly exactly and the gift
to me
is um i mean god which i do believe
i mean people can think i'm corny or
disagree well you went to divinity
school
right right well so god said hey take
take a year off right meet new people
and interact with those people in new
ways and that was the gift i got this
year
where is the opportunity and the crisis
yeah
yeah i mean it's amazing when you think
i mean for us
let's if you go back to march 12th i
think it was march 12th whatever the
date was
bang like overnight we lost a third of
our
revenue within two months bang we lost
another third of our revenue
right you know just our business was
truly destroyed our ability to keep the
doors open was
massively imperiled how many people do
you employ
we were i think we had 33 at the time
and now we have like 24.
i mean it it ravaged us yeah and we're
the live you were doing like that
that kind of road show right like on the
hudson you were doing
curating evenings with kelly and yes
yeah yeah
anything most of what we did live i mean
if you look at it if you look at our
entity as a as a means of survival
gathering live is
our business um and that was
totally eliminated right so that was
really scary that was really intense and
so
we were going to build this platform
anyway that was already in the plan
before covid came along
and thankfully um you know
supporters and others helped us get into
a position to say we're going to build
this thing as best we can it's funny
when everyone agreed to do that which
was around april 1st
we still thought we'd meet this fall and
that we'd still have revenue
opportunities between tickets and other
things that we do to sort of pay the
bills
and then on june 1st when we shut it
down like that was hard
yeah well when it all began i don't
think any of us could have
imagined that come september october
that we'd still be
in this lockdown situation no
no it's very it's it's it's just a crazy
interesting thing you know i do these
shows with rp eddie
you know right and um are you still
doing those every day every
no but i do them twice a week and um
rp eddie's the guy who built for bill
clinton
the pandemic plan and he had warehouses
full of ppe
and ventilators and all the stuff it was
all sitting in warehouses
and uh he wrote a book two and a half
years ago that said
it's coming soon here it is
so he he knows what he's talking about
and he he advises
you know governments and companies all
over the world on covid
and um you know the thing about kova
that i just find so fascinating
is that mathematically it's pretty
straightforward like it's pretty
straightforward that
this thing's flying around it's flying
around all the time if you wear a mask
and you stay away from each other and
you keep your hands clean and you stay
outside
you're in pretty good shape pretty good
shape and if you're not you're kind of
going to be screwed it's just a matter
of time
and then every other part of it all you
know is
a psychological interaction with what i
just said
and it's overwhelming now in certain
cases there are people who obviously are
in very difficult if you're a bus driver
for example
that's a shitty that's a difficult
situation if you're a nurse if you're a
doctor
you're in a tough spot for most of the
rest of us
it's it's a question of sort of what do
we want to endure and at what price and
and i don't know like these colleges
open and then
i don't know there's 250 kids sick here
and 500 kids sick there and
like there's no sensibility there's no
logic in all of this it's being driven
by politics and economics
i mean i feel like we're in this
no-man's land in the middle here where
we're kind of half-assing it
which means we're just going to
perpetuate this ad infinitum if
everybody went home for two weeks and
didn't leave their house
we you know we could really get on top
of this
but we're not going to do that and when
you see these colleges opening they're
opening because
they've got bills to pay and if they're
going to survive there they have no
other choice and so it's no surprise
that
even with the two-week sort of
quarantine that these students have to
undergo
in their dorm rooms college campuses are
not hermetically sealed environments of
course there's going to be outbreaks and
kids are going to do what kids do
yeah i mean straight up and you know
what it's like to be
19 and like you're invincible like who
cares
right so of course this is happening so
short of
hurt immunity or a safe vaccine
we're going to just be in this state i
think yeah
yeah it you know he he so when i did the
first trip so that was may 5th
uh when i got to wheeling west virginia
and i went to check into the hotel like
nobody
had a mask on and then there were a
variety of states throughout the trip
where that was the case
this trip we left on july 17th there was
a restaurant in michigan i went into and
nobody had a mask on the rest of the
trip everyone was wearing masks
there were masks in the delta in
mississippi there were masks in alabama
there were masks in missouri there were
masks
i mean totally interesting and that that
that definitely
contravenes what i would suspect based
upon my twitter feed
right right no it the masks masks are
everywhere and and
i i think what happens is i mean it's so
interesting because we're so
remember remember that the picture from
the pool in missouri
and it was like yeah
yeah well that's what the italians
thought of us
i mean when the italians like look at
the americans what are they doing
and then you know like look at the
people in missouri like what are they
doing
look at the people in manhattan i mean i
don't know if you remember the early
days in manhattan they chose shots
inside bars
in manhattan this is a weird thing man
we live in a time where
we actually knew the truth we as a
species knew the truth but how the truth
gets laid out through a culture
is a really interesting dynamic and then
even though the president
said i forget how we put it like be
courageous and do your own thing
well even his own supporters after a
while were like i'm gonna put a mask on
now
you know well it's this weird rugged
individualism that's woven into the
fabric
of our identity that is at odds with
what we need to do in order to
like cohere around a strategy that will
get us over the hump here yeah
yeah what is rp eddie's
perspective well i mean i think he
he's getting more hopeful on a vaccine
um and i think he thinks we will get
back to a more normal life around may of
next year
um and i would say that he
you know i think he looks at the
dynamics of um
how this will all kind of come together
culturally as minute to minute like it's
you know i would also say i mean he's an
interesting guy in the sense that he
worked for george w bush
he worked for hw and he worked for
clinton
mm-hmm anymore you know so he he he goes
both ways
the administration's right but he is
very negative on this administration in
this world and and feels like
beginning now like he throughout he said
september and october
are going to be very hard months
because of the election largely and all
the dynamics that will come into play
with that
you know i think i think he's he's an
eternal optimist type
but he is very anxious about what's
about to happen
yeah well i think that's a whole other
podcast we could do i know it really is
um
i gotta let you go you got other things
you gotta do but uh this was great thank
you i really
greatly appreciate uh the work that you
do
the care and the heart and the attention
that you put into it i think it's rare
there are a lot of things that you could
be doing with your time and the fact
that you're so
devoted to conversation
and to how to share what's meaningful
and important
speaks loudly about who you are as a
person so i'm proud to call you
a friend again we've known our we've
known each other our whole lives but
we've really gotten to know each other
quite a bit better in the last couple of
years and and that's been
very meaningful and and healing to me so
i appreciate that
and i'm here for you man anything i can
do to yeah well i feel the same i i um
you know a lot of the things that i went
through in the last few months
which again i'm just one guy we all went
through a lot of stuff in the last three
months
um but then i just sort of look at where
the world is now
and um you know
the work one is i i really admire your
um
point of view right and point of view is
a gift if it's you know diligently
arrived at and i think your point of
view is diligently arrived at
um and then two the same thing i just
think you know your willingness to sort
of
get out there and share those things um
i'm not trying to pick on this one guy
but i i do think of you as sort of
another end of an important spectrum and
that is um
i forgot i i think it was last year that
facebook netted 26 billion dollars right
and just that's an overwhelming another
just to
just to compare it like ford motor
company netted like three billion in
their best year
so they netted 26 billion dollars and if
you own
facebook well you have to net 32
the next year right some number bigger
like that's your job
and if you start asking yourself the
question how you're gonna arrive at that
bigger number
it's a bummer it's a bummer on what that
does to our culture and and
i'm okay like it's america like do your
thing
but i think that you sit on the other
end of that that spectrum
largely i mean we all have our own
contradictions in the way we interact
with the digital world
for better for worse and there's better
for sure and i want to be clear on that
even within facebook
um but that's a massive
important war that we're in right now
it's just it's a big deal
so i appreciate you doing what you do
yeah thanks man
uh we'll come back when you figure out
what's going on with this documentary
i will i'll know a lot in the next
publicly and uh
and we'll talk more about it man thank
you love you thanks so much
i appreciate you thank you peace plants
[Music]
you